in this case x gets converted to a
boolean truth value to decide
which way the if goes it's up to the
language to decide how this conversion
happens
so you can end up with contradictory
results like this
in python if empty string will give you
false
but in c plus or in c if
empty string will give you true
effective programmers need to know the
rules of their language
so let's take a look at the rules for
python c plus plus and
c as a bonus we'll get to see some of
the inner workings of how c python is
written
in python the rule is that literal true
is true
literal false and none are false a
number like object is false if it
represents some kind of
zero and a container is false if it
represents
something that's empty everything else
by default
is true this explains why python thinks
the empty string is false because it's
like an empty container of characters
there are actually two ways that a class
can opt out of the default true
conversion though
and a lot of you might not know the
second one the first way is the obvious
one
just define a dunderbool magic method of
the class
and put in your own logic the second way
is by defining a dunder length magic
method
basically if you define a length for
your class python assumes it's a
container
so if you return 0 you get false and
anything else you get true
but how do i know this is the way that
it works
the rule is buried somewhere in the
documentation but i saw the audience
drop off the last time i tried to show
docs on screen
so i found a better way in the modern
day we have compiler explorer to show us
where to look
yes compiler explorer works with python
and a number of other languages
it just shows you bytecode instead of
assembly though for some reason it only
supports up to 3.8
hint hint when i put a basic if x
into compiler explorer it shows me the
byte code instruction to look at is
called
pop jump if false so i just need to look
in python source for what that code does
this file is c eval dot c and see python
source here we see how pop jump if false
is handled
it checks for literal true and
literal false doing what it's supposed
to do in either of those cases
and then otherwise it calls this
function pi object
is true to determine whether or not the
object
is true or false this function pi
object is true is found in object dot c
and it's where the bulk of the real
logic happens
it checks for literal true false and
none and then checks to see if a dunder
bool is defined
calling it if it exists otherwise it
checks in two places if dunder length is
defined calling it if it exists
or just returning one to signal the
default true
negative numbers here are for errors so
that's the final answer for python it
uses dunderbool then
under length otherwise you get the
default true
what about c plus plus for numbers the
rule is the same as python
zeros are false and everything else is
true
arrays are treated like pointers to
their first element
and pointers are treated like numbers so
a null pointer is false and
all other pointers are true that
explains why the empty string literal is
true in c
plus plus because in c plus plus the
empty string literal is a
single element character array which
points to some valid non-zero memory
location storing a single null
terminator
it's not treated like an empty container
like in python
in fact it's not common in c plus plus
for a container to have its truth value
determined by whether or not it's empty
if x doesn't even compile for most
standard containers like standard string
or standard vector
but there are some like standard
optional where it does compile
by default if you just define your own
class or struct
if x is just not going to compile but if
you want if x to work all you need to do
is define an operator bool member
function
compiler explorer shows us that this
operator bool
is the thing that gets called to do the
conversion of x
into a boolean for the if statement pure
c on the other hand well c doesn't do
stuff for you if it's not a number
pointer or array if x just isn't going
to compile
define your own function be explicit and
convert your x to a bool yourself
hey everyone james murphy here thanks
for watching and thanks to my patrons
for their support
a huge shout out to jameson for becoming
my very first
exponential to your patron thank you for
showing your support
it means a lot to me to see my
supporters willing to support so much
don't forget to subscribe comment slap
that like button an odd number of times
ring the bell and enable notifications
so you can hear my next ramblings as
soon as they come out
see you next time